Film Courage: How many feature scripts have
you written?
Jeremy Foley, Filmmaker/Actor/Screenwriter:
Oh gosh, let me think… feature scripts we
have written…one…two ( I have to count)…probably
seven or eight feature scripts and then probably
oh two or three television or teleplay scripts
you know shorter like pilots or you know our
podcast script or so so probably about a dozen
scripts in total and then within those dozen
completed scripts you know certainly we have
a you know a giant board with all of our ideas
and then we have a lot of treatments for things
that we've written and we've written a lot
of you know we've written a lot of pitch decks
for a lot of our projects and we've written
a lot of series bibles or series pitches for
a lot of our television projects so yeah a
lot of a lot of writing a lot of writing but
yeah we think I would say about a dozen probably
feature screenplays and when you first started
writing these features who would you send
them to for reading you know when we first
started writing features I think there was
probably probably about there was there was
two major things we would do I guess I would
say or I think would recommend for people
I mean certainly like your friends if if you
have friends in the industry fantastic that's
great send them to those friends and even
if you don't have friends in the industry
still anybody who's willing to read it I would
say send it to them because it can it can
take people a while to read a screenplay and
get back to you but also I think what was
really helpful for us in the early days is
you can find there's there's many of them
online the you know there are screenwriting
services or screenwriting consultancy agencies
and screenwriting contests things like that
but I think what was really helpful for us
and we first started we would do a lot of
those because I think what's helpful is the
turnaround time as I said like you can of
course and and I recommend getting the scripts
to your friends and family and people like
that or people in the industry if you know
it but of course it can really take people
a while to read a screenplay think about it
get back to you you know we're all busy everybody's
you know doing something or doing their job
or they've got their own scripts so I think
a big benefit in the early days for us of
sending it to those screenwriting like coverage
places or consulting agencies was just the
turnaround time you were able to get it in
you know sometimes it's it's quick sometimes
it's you know 72 hours or a week or two weeks
and I think especially when you're at least
for us when you're just starting out having
that instant feedback or or quick turnaround
feedback was really helpful because we could
keep up the momentum of our script you know
what I mean like when you're writing it like
being able to get notes quickly would help
us just get back into a draft and really either
keep on shaping it or keep adjusting things
that maybe didn't work so well or and maybe
if we did hear that they were working well
you know we would we would leave them and
I think another benefit to sending it to those
agencies you know those screenwriting competitions
or consulting consulting agencies was you
know you're just doing it blind like if you
send it to your family or your friends they
know you maybe perhaps they even know the
story of the screenplay and when you send
it to those people it's just you know it's
anonymous so it's like I think they can give
you sometimes you know brutal feedback or
honest feedback about what's really working
or what's not working and they're not necessarily
as concerned about you know your feelings
or or how you know the story or you know they
don't necessarily know that it was maybe something
that happened to you or something from your
past or whatever it is they really just focus
on that script so I would suggest that and
I think that's a really helpful thing to do
and I know that helped us a lot in the beginning
do you think Hollywood's closed off I don't
think Hollywood's closed off I think I think
you know again because I've been doing this
for so long I think Hollywood and I've been
in the business 25 years 25 or 20 plus years
you know I think it's more open now than probably
I've ever seen it before because of social
media I think you know I know social media
is like a double-edged sword like you know
you have outrage over game of thrones episodes
but you can also like really I've seen a lot
of people like really legitimately advance
their careers as actors or screenwriters or
directors whatever it is because they're they're
just releasing stuff online they're able to
find an audience and then use that to kind
of you know catapult themselves into something
else or to find a representation as a as a
writer or as an actor director and I think
another thing actually is kind of cool about
you know Hollywood becoming more open and
with social media too you know you have things
like crowdfunding that never existed before
and I've you know we've crowdfunded ourselves
and it's just been like an amazing resource
and we were able to do so much more for our
films because we did have we were able to
generate those funds so no I don't think Hollywood
is closed off I think that this is probably
the most open I've ever seen it are you okay
if the two of you never get a feature film
made will you be okay with shorts and little
you know web series and things like that no
no to answer your question I we are really
always striving for that feature film that
is really important to us you know important
to me and important to Sara my partner you
know we we love film and we love television
and we've made a lot of really wonderful short
films films that we're really proud of and
we're gonna continue making them we're gonna
continue writing scripts and making webisodes
and podcasts but there's one thing that we
really haven't fully tackled yet and I don't
think we can really cross that off cross our
list you know our bucket list so to speak
our filmmaking bucket list until we hit the
future and so that's something we're still
pushing towards and I think you know we've
gotten close many many times and obviously
the the pandemic that we've all just went
through and that we're starting to come out
of now is sort of through everybody for a
for a loop I know a lot of filmmaker friends
and actor friends and I know a lot of people's
projects were sort of put on hold some people
were able to continue working but but I think
yeah I think that made a lot of people lose
momentum so I think now that everything's
back I think we're ready to to you know throw
our hat in the ring again and go after the
feature next and are you too cautious in in
terms of you want to do it right like you
know I see people do amazing crowdfunding
campaigns but then it turns out oh we didn't
raise enough we've got to go back and I know
that's difficult yeah to and it happens it
it happens with everything in life it's this
amount the time I couldn't I couldn't even
tell you how many stories I've seen about
people making features that have taken them
years literally years to make one feature
where they you know shoot something and then
a year later come back and shoot something
else and these aren't documentary features
where you can you know these are narrative
feature films where you're using the same
actors for you know sometimes years at a time
I've heard so many stories like that and and
so yeah we are a little bit cautious and the
films that Sara and I enjoy making and the
things we like to do are kind of high concept
a little bit complex or a little bit complicated
there's a lot of usually there's a lot of
moving parts in our short films and in in
our webisodes and in things like that so we
are cautious I don't think we're ready we're
I don't think we're going to jump into a feature
until we kind of feel like we have you know
there's you're never going to feel completely
comfortable you're always no matter what you
do I think making films you're always there
there's always a an unknown you know always
always and there's always going to be a million
problems every day but yeah we are we are
being a little bit cautious about exactly
how we're going to jump into a future but
I i'm hoping that you know from the experiences
we've had on all of our shorts and just with
all of the festivals we've been to you know
I think we can kind of see a little more of
of where it could go wrong and so we're it's
it's really going to be about trying to kind
of course correct ahead of time so it doesn't
go wrong while we're in the moment do you
have a date a target date like
2025 the feature will be finished you know
we I we don't have a target date of when we're
trying to make a feature and I feel like at
least for me personally I've kind of tried
to get over that idea that I need to have
it done at a certain time or I need to be
a certain age or I need to you know x, y,
and z needs to fall into place before I can
go out and do it i'm trying not to let myself
get distracted by that but I do want to focus
first on making it excellent and also making
it realistic something that we can accomplish
and accomplish well you know set out to do
and really execute it at a very high high
level but you know for whatever budget we're
able to to to get or to finance it for I guess
if that makes sense like I want to make sure
like we're we're being realistic and that
we're just gonna we're really going to deliver
that so that's more important to to me and
to us than to put a ticking clock on it.
Question For The Viewers:
How many feature films have you written?